we hope and pray that god gives you the
strength and courage to face these awful
times we stand with you she's collected
hundreds of messages and raised
thousands of pounds to send to ukraine
but lisa kay wants to do more this room
is all ready for two children a british
family who fled from kiev will arrive at
her home in warwickshire this weekend
she wants to give her other spare rooms
to ukrainians
i'd like to be able to look after them i
think they've been through absolute hell
and for me
it makes me feel
guilty
that i can just sit here and have all
this space
and then there's those people that have
had to leave like their dads and
brothers and
uncles and grandfathers behind it
just really really gets to me
the government says it will set out more
detail in the coming days about how
british people will be able to offer up
their homes to ukrainian refugees but it
follows heavy criticism of the home
office for the delays and red tape being
faced by people trying to get into this
country
at this refugee support centre they have
many questions we don't know the
logistics of this scheme yet
and we don't know the eligibility
criteria how long they will be able to
stay in the uk hopefully access to
employment study and benefits
and even better refugee status support
to find employment
registering with gps
school places for their children this is
my grandad
grandma
my aunt the details will matter to
families like julius their hometown now
in russian control they escape to poland
and are waiting to see if the uk will
allow them in she has this plea please
make it
faster
because it's very time consuming for
elderly people and people with children
like in my case let them come and then
i'm sure that all of the documentation
can be handed in in the uk already where
they save
the british public have already shown
their willingness to help will that
extend to opening their homes to those
most in need becky johnson sky news in
the west midlands